la richesse de l'Ukraine volée par
l'envahisseur
depuis le début de la guerre la Russie
se serait approprié près d'un quart du
grenier à grain de l'Europe de la
récolte à l'export un système de
contrebande bien rodé et très efficace
selon les chiffres de la NASA dans les
territoires occupés par la Russie depuis
début mars 5,8 millions de tonnes de blé
ont été moissonnés spolié aux Ukrainiens
d'après le Financial Times une
entreprise russe a été créée
spécifiquement pour organiser ce vol de
masse son nom sted graine operator dans
des vidéos de propagande le patron ne
cache pas ses méthodes
on a trouvé une propriété abandonnée les
gens abandonnent leur bien ils
abandonnent aussi leurs employés donc
nous y allons et nous mettons cette
entreprise sous notre contrôle
protecteur
après le vol ces trafiquants vont
littéralement blanchir les marchandises
l'objectif caché l'origine des céréales
pour pouvoir les exporter à l'étranger
première méthode la falsification de
documents le 10 août à 17h57 le Powell
un bateau syrien et dans le détroit de
kersch il est vide il est inséradar et
réapparaît 5 jours plus tard cette fois
il est plein d'où vient sa cargaison lui
prétend que c'est du gras russe chargé à
port-cafcase document à l'appui problème
sous les radars il se serait en fait
rendu à Berdiansk en zone occupée ces
images satellites analysées par des
experts maritimes l'identifie il est
chargé entre le 12 et le 13 août
le navire peut ensuite reprendre la
route comme si de rien n'était vers le
porte turc de oppa mais la plupart du
trafic s'organise à Sébastopol en Crimée
en huit mois
848000 tonnes de céréales ont été
expédiés depuis ce port près de 15 fois
plus qu'à la même période l'année
dernière
ce véritable blanchiment de blé est en
fait le plus grand succès de l'opération
russe
ils ont volé des milliards d'euros de
céréales
pour brouiller les pistes l'export se
fait parfois en deux temps des petits
bateaux chargent à Sébastopol puis
s'approche du détroit de Kirch là ces
images satellites de mijuan la teste un
grand cargo à temps bord à bord avec une
grue flottante la marchandise des petits
navires est transférée sur le plus gros
et le cargo peut ensuite prendre la
route des ports internationaux sans que
l'origine de ces céréales volés ne soit
identifié